ان نتابع معكم في هذه التطورات اللافته
وغير المسبوقه حيث اتهم رئيس مجموعه فاغنر
القوات الروسيه بقصف قواته وتوعد
بالانتقام واتهم رئيس فاجنر بريجين وزير
الدفاع الروسيه باصدار الامر بقصف قواته
في اوكرانيا وقال انه سيقرر كيفيه الرد
على الفضائع بعد قصف مواقع فاجنر وسيقرر
الخطوه التاليه وقد نفت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه قصف قوات فاغنر
هذه الصور الان نشرتها قوه فاجنر لما تقول
بانها المواقع لقوات فاغنر التي تعرضت
للقصف واتهم رئيس مجموعه فاجنر بريجوجن
القوات الروسيه بانها اقدمت على هذا القصف
واتهم مباشره وزير الدفاع الروسي سرغو
باصدار الامر بقصف قواته في اوكرانيا اذا
هذه الصور التي نشرتها قوات فاغنر لما
تقول بانها المنطقه او المراكز العسكريه
والمعسكرات التابعه لفاجنر والتي قصفت من
قبل القوات الاوكراني ابن القوات الروسيه
بحسب ما يقول بريجوجن وقال بانه سيقرر
كيفيه الرد اذا نعود ونذكر بما قاله
بريجوجن قبل قليل اتهم رئيس شركه فاغنر
يفغيني وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بخداع الرئيس
الروسي والشعب الروسي بالترويج بان
اوكرانيا تتحالف مع الناتو لمواجهه روسيا
وقال ان المبررات التي تم الاستناد لها
لغزو اوكرانيا منذ البدء كانت مبنيه على
اكاذيب بحسب وصفه
تحاول وزاره الدفاع خداع الرئيس والشعب
الروسي بالترويج ان اوكرانيا تتحالف مع
النيتو لمهاجمه روسيا والعمليه الخاصه
انطلقت لاسباب مختلفه كليا
واضافت بان الجيش الروسي بدا يتراجع في
خرسون
تحت وطاه الهجمات الاوكرانيه وهاجم قاده
وزاره الدفاع متهما اياهم باخفاء معلومات
عن تطور المعارك ميدانيه
ابتداء من اليوم شرع الجيش الروسي في
التراجع في خرسون وزافولوجيا تحت وطاه
الهجوم الاوكراني نحن نغرق بدمائنا ولا
احد يمدنا بتعزيزات القياده غائبه قاده
وزاره الدفاع يقومون بخداع الرئيس الذي
يتلقى تقارير لا تعكس ما يجري على ارض
الواقع هناك روايتان ما يجري في الميدان
وما يتم اعلام الرئيس به
اذا بعد هذه التصريحات خرج مجددا وقال بان
القوات الروسيه قصفت معسكرات تابعه وهذه
الصور التي نتابعها الان هي صور نشرتها
قوات فاغنر لما تقول بانها المواقع
التابعه لها والتي قصفت من قبل القوات
الروسيه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه متهما
مباشره وزير الدفاع الروسي سرجي بانه اصدر
امره بقصف قوات فاجنر في اوكرانيا في هذا
الموقع تحديدا التي الذي نعرض صوره الان
طبعا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه نفت وقالت انه
لا صحه للادعاء
بقصف المعسكر وهذا الاتهام مناف للواقع
وهو استفزاز اعلامي بحسب ما قالت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه